let's talk a little bit about the
structure of the cell i've done a lot of
videos where we deal with things that go
on inside of them but i haven't done one
where we just talk about the entire
structure of them so a good place to
start
is let me just draw the membrane and the
the cellular membrane is a good place to
start because this is what separates the
cell from the outside world and to a
large degree it kind of defines the cell
it defines it as this very very small
compartment that's where the word cell
came from so let me label that
cellular
cellular membrane
and all cells have a cellular membrane
now if we
if we think about the maybe the most
important thing that defines a cell
you've probably seen in the dna videos
and we'll talk about translation and
transcription all of that that what
defines what a living organism is is its
dna so all cells have dna inside of it
and i won't go into the details of how
dna defines what an organism is i've
done that in some detail on the dna
videos but all cells have dna here this
is more of a kind of an anatomy of a
cell video than
necessarily the function but we'll go
into the function because we need to
know what these different parts do so
this is right here this is the dna
this is the dna and it's in its
chromatin form here there's also little
proteins here
there's protein not in all organisms but
we're going to stick to eukaryotes and
i'll talk a little bit about the
difference between eukaryotes and
prokaryotes in a second but you have dna
as i've drawn the cell right now this is
pretty much
any cell any cell in any animal or plant
or whatever kingdom could look like this
i haven't drawn a lot of the details
i've just drawn the dna and the cellular
membrane now here's kind of the first
major division in the living world or at
least from our point of view
or that you know it seemed obvious is
that some cells have a membrane around
the dna
around the dna so they'll have a
membrane around the dna that separates
the dna and the chromatin and everything
that makes up the stuff within the dna
separates that from the rest of the cell
and this is called a nucleus
this is called
a
nucleus and i said that's a major
division because when some people looked
at some cells and they saw nucleus and
other cells and they didn't see nucleus
they say hey this is a good way to
classify organisms so they called things
that had nucleuses
eukaryotes
these have a nucleus so as i've drawn
this cell right here it is a eukaryote
now if you do not have a nucleus you are
dealing with a prokaryote
prokaryote no
no
nucleus and examples of prokaryotes the
two big groups of them are bacteria
and archaea
and archaea are really interesting we
know very very little about them they
were
originally thought to be types of
bacteria but now people are realizing
that they're this whole completely other
group and we we've actually observed a
very small subset of them so it's very
fascinating group and actually turns out
that evolutionarily speaking you
shouldn't make this division first that
it actually makes more sense to divide
things into
eukaryotes i'll just write that euk
bacteria
and archaea that you don't want to do
this division first they're actually
three separate groups that you want to
start off with okay we'll do that we'll
talk more about this in future videos
but if you want to say who has a nucleus
well eukaryotes have a nucleus by
definition who does not have a nucleus
well the bacteria and the archaea do not
have nuclei just like that but i'm going
to focus on eukaryotes because they tend
to be a little bit more complex they
tend to be larger and most of what we
talk about at least in the video so far
are dealing with eukaryotes you know
eukaryotes include
plants
animals where animals at least
i am
animals
and fungi and there are other there are
other groups within eukaryotes but these
are the ones that we normally
deal with in our everyday world but
let's go back to looking at the anatomy
of cell so we have our dna we know that
it gets transcribed into mrna that mrna
that mrna leaves the nucleus
and it gets translated into proteins at
the ribosomes
so the ribosomes
are these little complexes that could be
floating all over the cell and we'll see
in a second that they can also be
attached to these other membrane
structures so this is a ribosome
ribosome
and if all this talk of dna
transcription into mrna and mrna leaving
the nucleus and traveling to the
ribosome to be translated into proteins
makes no sense to you there are several
videos where i go into that in detail
what i want to do is just focus on all
of the different parts kind of give a
big picture of things so ribosomes are
where mrna
that gets transcribed inside the nucleus
from dna where it gets translated
translated into proteins
so you can kind of view them as the
place where information actually turns
into proteins which then can be used
anywhere else in the cell now one
interesting and these ribosomes they're
made up of proteins and actually they're
made up of
of rna and so one question is well where
are where are the pieces of the
ribosomes made well some are made by
proteins which might be made in other
ribosomes but some of it the mrna
ribosomes you can kind of view them as
this big you know this mess if you were
to d
look detailed if there's some protein
there
and i'm not drawing it that
realistically but then you have some
mrna
tied in with the protein and the mrna
isn't used for actual
information purposes like it normally is
when it goes from dna to the ribosome
within the ribosome itself ribosomal rna
is actually used as part of the
structure it actually helps the ribosome
function as a ribosome so it's actually
part of the ribosome and all of that all
of that gets built
in a part
in a part of the nucleus called the
nucleolus or the nucleole let me let me
let me write that down
so this right here
this is interesting right here this is
the nucleolus
the nucleolus or the nucleole and it
isn't a separate organelle and it's not
separated by a membrane but it shows up
in a microscope so when people first saw
that hey there's like a bundle there
there must that must be like the core of
the nucleus or something but it turns
out what it is it's the densely packed
you got dna and rna and that's actually
where the ribosomal rna the stuff that
makes up the ribosomes is actually
produced but it's so dense that it shows
up on a microscope and that's why people
decided to name it something different
but it is not membrane-bound it's not an
organelle within an organelle it's just
densely packed
of proteins and ribosomal rna it's where
ribosomal rna gets produced
so anyway we're at the ribosome that's
where proteins get produced but if the
ribosomes are just floating around if
they're free ribosomes then those
proteins will just you know once they're
produced at the ribosome they'll just
float around here and the fluid inside
the cell that we call the cytosol
cytosol but what if
what if we wanted to produce proteins
that are supposed to end up maybe in the
membrane of the cell or maybe outside of
the mim the cell itself you know cells
produce things that are used by other
cells that are used by the rest of the
body and here we have to go to proteins
that are attached to this membrane you
can kind of view it as a bunch of
tunnels
let me see how well i can draw it i'm
going to draw it very roughly
you have this thing called the
endoplasmic reticulum
you can just view it as a
bunch of tunnels like that
endoplasmic reticulum
and they eventually lead to something
called golgi bodies named after mr golgi
himself
so i'll do the endoplasmic reticulum in
yellow and i'll do the golgi bodies
i'll do the golgi bodies in green maybe
just like that and i'll tell you in a
second what they are
so what's going this is kind of a a big
kind of stack or or you can kind of view
it as a bunch of folded membranes
together and some ribosomes are actually
attached to this part which i call the
endoplasmic reticulum so we have we have
ribosomes attached some of them are free
some of them are attached let me write
my labels down so this right here and we
use the space over here
this
big flap of of of of convoluted membrane
that's the endoplasmic reticulum endo
plasmic
reticulum it's fun to say
endoplasmic reticulum maybe a a good
name for a band endoplasmic reticulum
and the parts that have ribosomes
attached to it are called the rough
endoplasmic reticulum maybe even a
better name for a band
so right here
or if i've attached ribosomes
so these ribosomes are attached right
here this is the rough endoplasmic
reticulum or maybe the rough er
the rough
rough er er standing for endoplasmic
reticulum and then where we don't have
any ribosomes attached that's the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum
so right here that is the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum i'm going to tell
you in a second what this is but we can
keep following the membranes eventually
we get the golgi bodies
golgi
bodies and now what happens is i gave
you a hint in our free ribosomes mrna
gets there it gets translated to
proteins and the proteins then just
float around in the cytosol but what if
we want proteins that should end up in
membranes or that end up outside of the
cell and that's where the endoplasmic
reticulum and and the golgi bodies come
into play because now what we can do is
we have mrna coming in coming outside of
the nucleus and it can attach to the
ribosomes or can be translated by the
ribosomes in the rough er and what
happens here is your mrna comes here
it's getting i know i drew that arrow
very small it's getting translated on
the outside of the endoplasmic reticulum
but as the protein gets produced it's
getting pushed into the inside of the
endoplasmic reticulum and when i say the
inside of the endoplasmic reticulum i'm
talking about this area this
i'm coloring it in this is the inside of
the endoplasmic reticulum
and so the proteins will get pushed into
the endoplasmic reticulum the ones that
are to be used outside of the cytosol
outside of the cell or maybe in the
cell's membrane so proteins will end up
here that's why those ribosomes are on
the membrane because it can translate
things that are outside of the
endoplasmic reticulum but as the
proteins get produced the the chain of
the amino acid chain ends up inside of
it let me make a let me make a blow up
of that because i think that'll be
useful
so let me draw an endoplasmic let me say
let's say this is the membrane of the
endoplasmic reticulum
and then you have ribosomes attached to
it
so let's say that's a ribosome on the
endoplasmic reticulum and this is going
to be the rough endoplasmic reticulum
and what you can have is mrna coming
into one side of it
get your mrna
mrna can kind of come in through here
maybe it's going in that direction it's
getting translated
into the proteins but then the protein
as it as the amino acid chain is built
up will pop out on this end
of the membrane remember this is our
membrane of our endoplasmic reticulum so
even though the mrna is on the outside
because the ribosome is attached to it
the protein can show up on the inside
and so that once the protein is built
maybe it folds all up you know protein
is just a folded chain of amino acids
it can travel through the endoplasmic
reticulum and it travels through it it
travels through the smooth endoplasmic
reticulum all the way and it gets to the
golgi bodies and all sorts of other
things happen i'm over simplifying
things but i just want to give you a
sense of what everything in the cell
does and once the protein travels to the
golgi bodies and they get ready for
traveling outside of the cell or maybe
traveling to the cell's membrane the
gold they'll actually butt out of the
golgi bodies so let's say the same
protein when it gets to the golgi bodies
remember it's inside of the golgi body
so let me draw the membrane of the golgi
body right there
the protein might end up there it's just
a big chain of amino acids and then it
will butt out so let's say it looks like
that and then maybe the next step it'll
look something like this
it'll look like
that
it'll look like that
and in the very next step you can
imagine it looks something like this
where it's actually completely butted
out it's taken
it's popped out a little of the membrane
of the golgi body with it
so now the protein is surrounded by its
own little membrane
right so let's think about what happened
we had dna transcribed into mrna mrna
goes to a ribosome that's attached to
the endoplasmic reticulum it is
translated into a protein that travels
through the endoplasmic reticulum first
the rough where all the ribosomes are
then the smooth the smooth has other
functions it also helps
it also helps i guess we could say
produce
hormones and another fatty compound but
i won't go into detail there but it just
travels it it connects to the golgi
bodies and the golgi bodies the proteins
can butt off and take a little bit of
the membrane with it and this idea of
something being surrounded by a membrane
and just traveling in the cell so maybe
the protein now looks like this
i'm enlarging it maybe the proteins
there and then it took a little bit of
the golgi body membrane with it
this is called a vesicle
this right here let me let's add another
one right here i'm just doing that to
label it
that's called a vesicle
and a vesicle is really just a very
general term for anything little small
things mostly proteins that in the cell
that are just floating around that are
surrounded by their own little mini
membranes and the reason why this mini
membrane is useful is now this protein
can now float to the outer membrane of
the cell it can also float to other
parts of the cell i'm doing a
simplification and then it can merge
either with the membrane of the cell or
it can use this membrane this little
vesicle membrane itself it has to
facilitate getting out of the cell you
can imagine that it eventually you know
this thing could let's say this is the
outer membrane of the cell and i'm doing
a gross over simplification i'm not even
drawing the bi-lipid layer but just to
have a visual impression of what it
might look like
is that's the vesicle there
the little protein inside of it and it
gets closer and closer to the membrane
and then it can merge with the membrane
because it's made up of the same stuff
it merges with the membrane
your protein inside actually i switch
colors arbitrarily but now all of a
sudden once it merges with the membrane
then the protein
can exit the actual cell or maybe it can
actually embed itself within this
membrane within the outer cellular
membrane which i drew very thin but it
can it has
two layers to it we'll talk more about
that in a i could probably make a whole
video on it so those are you know we've
already made pretty good progress on uh
showing the anatomy of the cell there
are two a few other things we can throw
in there there are things called
lysosomes which are really
there's things called lysosomes which
exist in animal cells that contain prot
that control contain enzymes in them
that help dissolve other things
lysosome
so if a lysosome attaches to something
else and is able to spew its enzymes
into it it usually kills it it usually
digests it so that's what a lysosome
does
in
in ana in plants you have things called
lytic vacuoles and those are really the
same thing as a lysosome in terms of
their function in that they're really
big vesicles and in fact in general a
vacuole is just a big vesicle it's just
a general term for a big membrane-bound
organelle
vacuole
and once again what's an organelle let
me write down that word
or
ganel
it's just a membrane-bound i guess you
call it subunit of a cell just like my
liver is a subunit of cell an organ and
it's an organ an organelle is a subunit
of a cell so a vacuole is just a general
term for a membrane-bound organelle that
stores stuff inside of our cell so this
stores things
so a lytic vacuole would be a vacuole in
a plant cell that stores a bunch of
enzymes and if it were attached to
something else it would dissolve it if
it were able to spew its enzymes into
the other thing
now there's
several organelles that we've talked
about within the context of respiration
and photosynthesis and i go into detail
in those videos but we have things
called mitochondria
mitochondrion cells
and they have inner and outer membranes
and this is where this is where we
produce our energy where sugars are
turned into atp and i've done detailed
videos on this and these are actually
contain their own dna and they can
actually reproduce on their own which
makes a lot of so they have their own
dna which makes people believe that they
exist that they that their ancestors
once existed as independent prokaryotic
organisms that once you know at some
point they just kind of stumbled upon
the notion of hey why don't i live it
within inside other organisms and kind
of live in symbiosis so mitochondria
these are organelles that at one time
at one time their ancestors might have
been independent prokaryotes so those
are mitochondria let me write down
midochondria that's where cellular
respiration takes part and we go into
detail on that and then on the plant
cells this is only in well definitely
not in animal cells you have
chloroplasts which are a subset of thing
called plastids but chloroplasts are the
most famous maybe i should do that in
especially green green
so we have chloroplasts and we know they
have little thylakoids in there this is
where photosynthesis takes place you
have your grana and all of that and i do
go into detail in the photosynthesis
videos but it's good to know these are
other organizat organelles and just like
mitochondria they have their own dna in
their own ribosomes and so the belief is
is that they were once independent
prokaryotes that learn to live in
symbiosis with inside of larger
eukaryotic cells so we're almost done
really with the structure cells there's
other things we can throw on here
if we're dealing with plant cells
or really non-animal cells we'll have
something called a cell wall which will
give some strength to the outer membrane
you can kind of view it that way or you
could kind of get some rigidity
so you have things called cell walls so
they're not necessarily completely rigid
you can almost view them as balloons
that provide just a little bit more
rigidity
things like wood actually have double
cell walls first you know really
hardcore rigidity so this is a cell wall
cell
wall this is in non-animals
and in plants is made out of cellulose
not cellulite
cellulose that used to confuse me so
these this gives extra rigidity or form
to the cellular membrane
and then to actually give the cell its
actual structure
you have these things called
microfilaments or sometimes actin
filaments and these are these little
pipes that go throughout the cell and
these actually help give the cell its
actual
structure in three dimensions and
actually they actually can participate
in things moving around within the cell
or even the cell moving around itself
and just to be complete make sure we're
covering everything if you watch the
mitosis and meiosis videos you have
these things called centrioles and i go
into detail there centrioles
that are right outside of the nucleus
two centrioles that are at right angles
to each other make up a centrosome
and this is they kind of coordinate the
microtubules when we when we start
splitting the cells in mitosis and
meiosis so i won't go into detail there
i've done money videos on that as well
but so far this is pretty much
everything you need to know about or at
least a a a first overview of the
structure of the cell and you know in
one video we finally got it all in one
place this is pretty much
pretty much i haven't delved into detail
in everything on all of the major pieces
of the cell so hopefully you have a a
better big picture view of how things
are organized inside of it